what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight deaths prediction video this video
is actually part two so for those of you
that may have not seen my other death
predictions I will put that link down in
the description just in case any of you
still want to watch that one I'm also
doing a giveaway where I'm giving away
three different prizes to three
different winners so you still have
plenty of time to enter the giveaway if
you want that link will be down in the
description also the first place winner
was already announced and she contacted
me and asked for the asan of Ice and
Fire collection but the other two prizes
are still up for grabs
I still have the world of Ice and Fire
novel aim the Game of Thrones Monopoly
game to giveaway so good luck to the
rest of you that are participating now
let's get started the next character on
my death list is Songz a stark the
temporary queen of the north will die in
my opinion I just don't see Sansa
surviving this great war I don't expect
to see her on the battlefield with a
sword in her hand fighting the whole
time but I believe her lack of training
is going to get her killed she does have
her own protection but they're gonna be
busy fighting and I think there will
come a time during this war where Sansa
is gonna be left defending herself and
if that happens we all know how that's
going to end she's going to die when I
first started to watch this show and I
was introduced to the others beyond the
wall in the very first episode I knew
right then that there would come a day
that they would get on the other side of
the wall and they would make it to
Winterfell and disrupt the life as they
knew it there's only one season left so
everything is going to come to a peak
and reach its climax and one of the
remaining six episodes left the night
King and his army are already south of
the wall and they're making their way
south eventually they will make it to
Winterfell and that's where all hell is
gonna break loose for some reason I have
had this vision of thousands of whites
pouring over the walls at Winterfell and
I've always had this vision of seeing
the night king standing right inside of
Winterfell courtyard I think that would
be absolutely terrifying almost like the
worst nightmare coming true
the name Winterfell itself has several
meanings in my opinion I have said this
in other videos but I'm gonna say it
again right here I think this is where
the big battle will take place arguably
one of if not the best battle we have
ever seen will happen at winter
and this is where winter will fall one
more time and by winter I mean the king
of winter the night king but before he
falls in Winterfell there will be a ton
of casualties and one of those
casualties will be sons of Stark I think
the entire castle will be over ran with
white sand White Walkers and during the
battle songs that will find herself
having to pick up a sword and swing it
or die immediately because Brienne and
Arya and John and everybody else is
going to be fighting and they can't hold
songs his hand the entire time and her
lack of training is going to get her
killed also I'm sure that most of you
have read or heard about George RR
Martin's original draft by now but if
you haven't then I'm gonna let you know
back in 1993 george RR martin wrote a
3-page outline basically listing some of
the key points he was gonna write about
when he began writing his epic fantasy
novels and in that outline he revealed
the five main characters that he said
would survive the entire story and guess
what
Sean's a stark was not on that list now
George has changed a lot of this
original drafts since then but some say
his key characters have not changed and
if that's true then Sansa Stark will die
in his story and since Dan and Dave are
basing this show off of his story then I
can only assume they could do the same
George told the creators of the show how
he was going to end his story and they
plan on making their ending very similar
the only difference was how they would
get to that ending but now we are here
with only six episodes left I believe
they will keep and kill the same main
characters as George but who knows I
could be wrong about that too but since
I'm already talking about the great war
let's just move on to the next character
which is the knight King himself I know
the fan base is kind of divided on how
things will end but I believe the knight
king will be killed I don't think
there's gonna be any kind of peace
treaty or anything like that I've always
felt like the knight king would have to
be killed this time for good like I said
earlier I think the big battle will take
place in Winterfell the reason a stark
must always be in Winterfell is for this
reason to make sure the night king is
defeated because they always knew winter
was coming but everyone forgot what it
truly meant they didn't just mean that
the winter weather was coming it used to
mean that the king of winter from the
lands of always winter was coming and
when he makes it to Winterfell there
must all
be a stark there to ensure that winter
will fall and not take over the realm
there is a reason why brain stark in the
night King have such a strong connection
because this was always meant to happen
all of the events that have taken place
in this story thus far were already
predetermined in the night King is going
to arrive at Winterfell right on time as
the night king in his army head south
John and Daenerys and their forces are
going north where they will collide in
the greatest war of all time the true
battle for Winterfell but this time the
night King will be stopped for good the
game of thrones production crew have
already started making some renovations
on the Winterfell set this week someone
snapped some photos of them rebuilding
some of the castle walls and there's
only two reasons why I believe they're
gonna be doing something like this one
reason could be because Winterfell gets
partially destroyed during the war or
the Starks might be building some extra
defenses to help keep the others out of
the castle either way I do think this is
a good sign that there will be a war in
Winterfell and I can't wait to see it I
made a few other separate videos this
week too that some of you may have not
seen yet I made a video about the death
of Varys animated video about the death
of Melisandre both of those characters
are all my death list too so check out
those videos if you haven't watched them
already they did seem to get a good
response from most of you even from
those of you who disagreed still seem to
enjoy the videos I believe Daenerys
Targaryen is going to die also she
wasn't in any of my death prediction
videos but I did make a video about the
fate of Daenerys right before I started
this series of videos I think it's safe
to say that Jon and Daenerys are the two
big heroic characters right now and I
just don't see both of them surviving
this series not if there's gonna be a
bittersweet ending I don't think you can
keep both of the main characters alive I
think that would be too happy of an
ending unless John and Daenerys hate
each other by the end of the show what's
just possible I guess but I still feel
like Daenerys will die and I think there
is a very strong possibility that she
will die during childbirth while having
joins baby John and Danny's mothers both
died during child labour and I think
they could have the same thing happened
to Daenerys it would be better to see
her die before she was able to achieve
her dream of rolling to Seven Kingdoms
but it would be sweet to know that she
gave birth to a Targaryen heir that can
carry on her legacy and family
I think she could also end up being
John's Nissa Nissa too if they do the
whole Ozora hai thing in the show and
John has to plunge a sword into
someone's chest a forge Lightbringer
then that person could be Daenerys or
even Melisandre I have to put you on
Royce back on my list again - I did have
him on my death list for last season but
of course he was put on the sidelines
like a lot of other characters but I
have to believe what the Dead marching
towards Winterfell Yan Royce will be
taking part in this fight against the
dead and he will die this season at this
point he has pretty much became a
worthless character he really serves no
purpose to the story anymore since that
little [ __ ] sweet Robin has been cut out
of the plot - for now we might not see
Robin again they might not actually tie
up that loose end just like with Ed Mir
Tolly
and if this is the case then I'm pretty
confident Yan Royce will be added to the
list of dead when this war is all said
and done in the dust settles I have to
put your own great joy on this list - I
think there's no way in hell this maniac
lives happily ever after I made a video
before season 7 started and I went into
detail about how I think your own story
could end I believe Theon will kill him
during his rescue attempt for Yara now I
have to clarify this
Theon might die in the process but I
strongly believe Theon will be the one
to take your on down Yara tried to save
Theon while he was a prisoner of
Ramsay's and in season eight Theon will
return the favor but he will give a much
better effort than Yara did I believe
that is the tip of Theon's Redemption
arc they have kept this man alive for
all these years for a reason I think if
they wanted to kill Theon off before
this they could have killed him right
after he saved Songz's life but that
obviously wasn't the end of his arc
Fiona needs to face his fears see I'll
never get the chance to take Ramsey on
but he will get that redemption through
his uncle you're on I know it seems very
unlikely that Theon can pull this off
but trust me this will happen that
little speech that John gave to Fiona at
the end of season seven helped him
tremendously it gave him that closure
that he truly needed what the stark
family when John told Theon he was still
a stark it closed that hole left in his
heart from turning his back on Rob
now Theon did have many reasons to turn
his back on raw but regardless of the
fact
vielen has always felt hurt since
did this because he did it for the wrong
reason he did it for the wrong father
theone might have been award but he was
still a stark and here in John say those
words gave feeling the courage and
confidence again he faced his fear and
didn't run when he was confronted with a
challenge he kicked the Ironborn man's
ass and then he bent down and washed the
blood off his face with the salt water
and that was Theon's baptism what his
dead may never die but rises again
harder and stronger strong enough to
defeat his uncle euron greyjoy
I have Qyburn on my death list - I never
really made a video about Qyburn yet but
I think he will die in this final season
along with Cersei and the mountain but
I'm gonna have to make a separate video
about Kye burns death though because
it's gonna take me a while to explain
exactly how I think he's going to die so
let this be a little bit of a tease for
a future video because I think you will
enjoy my Qyburn death prediction I think
it makes perfect sense in my mind but
it's gonna take its own video for me to
explain it properly and to add a few
clips as evidence
I might actually make that the next
video so keep your eyes open for that
one and I will announce the next winner
in my next video - I already ordered and
shipped the a song of ice and fire
collection - Kiara James so I think it's
a good time for me to announce the next
winner in the very next video
in the person who gets randomly selected
next will get the pick whichever prize
they want between the world of ice and
fire novel in the game of thrones
Monopoly game so good luck to everyone
else that has entered the giveaway and I
want to thank everyone for watching
today's video I appreciate that as
always I also want to thank every single
one of my patreon supporters who
continue to support this channel month
after month that really does mean a lot
to me and I hope everybody has a great
day I will see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you